yeah welcome to the splits game playing
international master and leading Stein
this is funny and Nell played the sky
before is this on Doris interesting ok
we got them exchange rule or pass ok
let's cover the pawn all right not
exactly the most thrilling set up with
this rethink ok but it's a it's a fairly
solid way to play of course for what how
to continue now let's go here at 9726
he's am playing for a form ok
okay 50 I forgot about the spawn what
did you recapture with with the bishop
but then he will take him hmm yeah
taking with the porn it's not exactly
what I wanted okay probably should have
played be 6 mm before covering c5 but
it's not I don't think it's it's a huge
problem
it's still fairly solid position from
black yeah b5 is as a move you need to
consider carefully but you only had the
the capture so but was no problem can't
just take it yeah this looks like a
rather draw position yeah with the with
the bishops opposite colored bishops
okie one yeah okay not quite sure what
the idea is to give me the FL it's not
it's not like a great or anything but
why why do that in the first place okay
Bishop to g5
my dears to go edge form try to take a
little bit h4h three I think there are
some new way in terms of still drawing
even after you've you've risked
something before we probably just just
take it
can the curious there should be
something really hmmm maybe maybe
hmm not sure but on all of this h3b
should be seven Brooklyn well f-for 56
mm maybe he can he can really play that
yeah still I also just throw that I have
Queen 85 as a cavern can they cannot sec
the exchange fortunately
yeah yeah but I'm not I'm not sold on
this this law threatens look everyone
winning the Queen and that has got the
idea to capture look G for this is
rather risky I think what white played
them
yeah and now that's the big thing which
probably should have happened time
before okay just just take it you cannot
take g2 because of route g4 and I'm
threatening Bishop h3 and we have one
winning this is actually not so easy to
prevent and resins i guess like you know
yeah we played this too quickly just
grabbing this stuff I think it's just
just not working I mean this already is
looks dangerous off the computer things
right is in excellent shape with G 3m
this is possible of course just play g3
first I was just hoping that I can I can
just drop it back and just play on the
light squares but maybe this is nonsense
this weekend he can really take this was
what I was thinking and okay this for
human it looks rather shaky this King
position the computer has completely
unimpressed and thinks why does white as
much better yeah possible but i think
the capture was not Anya green g 5o
rookie three actually is good also I
looks dangerous look III Queen f6 son
with a mate threat Queenie one takes
King takes and the computer gives you
think this is a draw this line is a
drawn
yeah but why is this a draw actually not
sure when White's king is still a bit
airy but ok they're both whites pieces
are helping the defense zone maybe
m-maybe a drawers is fam or let's say an
equal position as the writer assessment
yeah thanks for watching